ville qui est la mienne, choisis-tu de
un lien
papier
ma sœur doit faire
donc il avait Allah
Bossini était plutôt une question
alors alors alors alors
et la souffrance peut être vue parce que la guerre alors
termes de cyclisme, dollars en diesel
Comme ça
nous avons du noir au crochet
ajoutez du thé pyramidal puis la photo appelée
D'accord
et puis non, moi
je suis ma sœur ou c'est tae
je
de tourbe
regarder la mise en scène de Jupiter partir
Sony choisit les voisins ne sont pas venus
noir ce papier
dans l'historique pour compléter sudhir
ou envoyer
que nos nerfs en tant que personnes
à
dans le
pas
peut-on être mère ensemble
Oh
est précis
être Éric
qui est l'opinion
est un outil alors
mais
Oui